Chris Patten Catherine Schwarzenegger
feel nothing but blessed one day after
tying the knot pretty magical that's
right et can confirm that the 39 year
old actor and the 29 year old daughter
of Arnold Schwarzenegger and Maria
Shriver then I do on Saturday at San
Ysidro Ranch in Montecito California I'm
a man of faith and I believe that God
works in mysterious ways and gives us
signs and gifts in life and those gifts
oftentimes come in the form of people
according to a source close to the
couple
the duo wanted to keep it simple but
have the most important people in their
lives there and on Sunday the newlyweds
gushed about the best day of our lives
on Instagram Mike Wow both Chris and
Catherine shared this photo from their
wedding day but exactly the same time
writing in part we became husband and
wife in front of God our families and
those we love it was intimate moving and
emotional we feel so blessed to begin
this new chapter of our lives according
to their post the bride's gorgeous gown
and the groom's dapper suit were
designed by Giorgio Armani this is not
something I ever imagined the marriage
marks Pratt second and Schwarzenegger
first the actress split from ex wife on
a ferris with whom he shares
six-year-old son Jack in August 2017
after eight years of marriage grudge
holding is not something that I think
Chris and I do and and so we we wanted
to make sure of course that Jack was
happy but that we were happy in
supportive of each other
crowd and Schwarzenegger were first
linked last June when they were spotted
picnicking together in Santa Barbara
California in December the actor made
their relationship Instagram official
with this sweet collage in honor of
Schwarzenegger as 29th birthday and by
January they were engaged after less
than a year of dating it just seems so
unreal a source told et at the time that
they got engaged quick but everyone
around them saw it coming
adding that they're a great couple that
have a solid foundation Pratt made his
red carpet debut with Schwarzenegger at
the Avengers end game premiere in April
where he opened up to et about how
wedding planning was going I'm up to
about my neck you know that's not that's
pretty deep that's about five foot
something's in here so you're in it I'm
in it baby how minute but it's good it
feels good you should be said it's a
good time we're all very blessed I feel
good man good time to be here for the
Avengers premiere and also good things
happening for me in life I just count my
blessings every day et has reached out
to both pratt & schwarzenegger reps for
comment
you